allez on va continuer avec une page
politique et municipale l' l'UMP à
presque don toutes ses investitures pour
les candidats qui se présentent dans les
villes détenu par un par un maire de
gauche c'est le cas notamment à
boisarsti Philippe Benassaya bonsoir
vous avez été désigné comme tête de
liste alors je rappelle quand même que
vous êtes Président c'est pas un hasard
parce que vous êtes président du groupe
de l'opposition au conseil municipal et
puis en 2008 vous étiez déjà sur la
liste UMP qui à l'époque était emmenée
par France quo Riber alors ma première
question malgré tout c'est que vous avez
pas l'impression que la tâche va être
quand même assez rude parce que je
rappelle qu'au dernier municipal en mars
2008 clu l' avait remporté dès le
premier tour avec plus de 64 % des voix
il avait en face de lui la listep de
François River mais il avait aussi une
liste dissidente à gauche alors ça va
vous AZ vous avez bon moral bah oui sur
les chiffres on se dit que c'est
compliqué quoi oui mais chaque élection
a sa propre vérité en 2008 le maire
était dans une dynamique euh il était à
la fin de son deuxè mandat malgré des
tiraillements puisqu'il y a une liste
comme vous l'avez rappelé dissidente de
gauche et puis disons que la droite
c'était c'était organisée un peu
tardivement avec une entrée en campagne
de François harribert un peu un
peu lente et et tardive ce qui fait que
on va dire que l'électorat de droite de
boisarcy n'a pas été n'a pas été touché
et resté à la maison comme on dit ce qui
fait que le bloc de gauche arcisien est
allé voter j'ai envie de dire presque
tout seul quoi rester à la maison je
vrais juste rappeler quelques chiffres
il y avait 7000 à peu plus de 7000
inscrits il y a eu 3000 vois pourill
1000 vois pour 1 vois quand même d'écart
sur un tout petit nombre d'insr ce qui
fait ce qui ça fait pas beaucoup c'est
bien ce que je dis ça fait pas faut y
aller faut y aller mais là la situation
on va peut-être en parler quand même
différente 6 ans après parce qu'en 6 ans
beaucoup de choses se sont passé sur en
6 ans ce qui a changé en tout cas c'est
que vous en 2009 François rber est parti
vous avez pris vous êtes devenu
président du du groupe d'opposition avec
l'ambition de rel lancer bois d'Arc pour
tous Aujourd'hui vous avez combien
d'adhérents est-ce que vous avez réussi
à relancer votre oui alors quand quand
je quand j'ai repris la présidence de
bois d'Arc pour tous on était une
dizaine de membres nous sommes
aujourd'hui en carté à peu près 150 sans
compter les sympathisants il y a une
très très très très grand engouement
notamment depuis
euh l'annonce par le maire
actuel de création de ce fameux cœur de
ville qui fait énormément débat à cœur
de ville c'est autour de la mairieour de
la la M un aménagement très très urbain
à très forte densification urbaine d'un
carrefour qui est déjà totalement saturé
ce qui fait que les arcisiens sont sou
vent debout contre ce projet mais le
maire n'entend rien nous nous avonster
on va par de axes de campagne on a bien
compris que l'urbanisation serait
certainement au cœur de de cette
campagne des municipale à bois d'Arc
mais d'abord votre stratégie alors
comment vous comment vous travaillez
pour ces municipales est-ce que vous
avez déjà commencé à faire soit du
tractage soit du porte à porte oui ben
une campagne électorale ne prépare pas 6
mois ou 9 mois avant ça fait depuis des
années que nous sommes sur le terrain en
porte à porte en réunion publique nous
nous travaillons les projets les axes de
campagne on va en parler une présence
très accrue au Conseil municipaux dans
les commissions on lâche pas on lâche
rien d'autant plus que je pense que
boadarcy a besoin d'un renouvellement et
a besoin de changer d'air dans les deux
sens du terme a et ere dans en ce sens
que aujourd'hui on est arrivé à mon avis
à la fin d'une époque et cette fin
d'époque ne fait pas l'élection mais
elle traduit chez les arcisiens un
besoin d'écoute d'attention de
renouvellement et d'envie de faire de la
politique autement vous dites on change
d'époque malgré tout les élections
municipales on vote pas tant pour un
parti que pour un homme une femme ENF on
v justement quand je parle de changement
d'époque je parle de la de la
municipalité actuelle je parle pas de
politique nationale vous savez boarc a
une anomalie hein les arcisiens votent à
droite au niveau national et depuis
95 1995 vote à gauche au niveau local
c'est pas la seule des communes mon
alors c'est l'invers
des équations personnelles qui jou il y
a des équations personnelles qui jouent
cette équation personnelle joue de moins
en moins je pense pour la municipalité
sortante il y a un essoufflement c'est
le 3ème mandat c'est vrai que c'est
difficile pour une équipe qui est à bout
de souffle en ce moment de proposer un
pacte de renouvellement pour les
arcisiens qui n'y croient plus tellement
et justement vous aimeriez avoir qui en
face de vous comme candidat est-ce que
vous aimeriez Claude huyet
l'actuellement qui effectivement on est
à son 3è mandat ou est-ce que vous ça
égal ça vous est égal est égal parce que
moi je regarde le projet qu'on propose
aux arcisiens je sais ce que les
arcisiens veulent je connais leurs
attentes je sais que nous allons dans le
dans le dans le dans la bonne direction
même si on va parler des axes là bientôt
mais on va dans la bonne direction alors
je sais que l'équipe est très divisée
l'équipe de gauche actuelle est très
divisé il y a eu un adjoint qui a été
démissionné un peu de manière avec assez
assez violemment d'ailleurs par Claude
Villier euh ça sent oui comme je dis ça
sent peu la fin de r mais c'est pas
notre problème c'est le le problème
problème ce sont c'est sont les
différentes thématiques et notamment
l'urbanisation c'est ça l'axefor oui oui
là franchement Bois d'Arcy subit
aujourd'hui deux gros projets de
densification urbaine dans deux
quartiers très précis de bois d'Arc un
quartier qui s'appelle la croix bonnaet
qui est un quartier très jeune très
moderne où le maire avait promis de ne
pas dépasser les 700 logements nous en
sommes aujourd'hui à 1300 et c'est pas
terminé c'est des beaux logements pas
tous quand je dis pas tous c'est parce
qu'il n a pas quand même un côté
écologique là il a un canal paysager qui
vient d'être côté quandême oui a un côté
qui est très joli mais il n a comme il
n'y a très peu de prescrip
architecturale recommandé dans le plan
local urbanisme de Bois d'Arcy tout le
monde fait un peu n'importe quoi et
l'aménageur fait un peu ce qu'il veut
euh et ça ça nous inquiète beaucoup
maintenant lorsqu'on fait des logements
lorsqu'on fait des des constructions il
faut aussi créer le quartier qui va avec
et c'est ce qui manque à la croix
bonnais c'est un quartier idem on en
parlait tout à l'heure en cœur de ville
donc sur la sur le le carrefour de la
mairie il y a un projet de 400 logements
qui va totalement asphixier non
seulement Bois d'Arcy mais qui va poser
des problèmes aux deux villes voisines
de boisarc de chaque côté du carrefour
c'est-à-dire fontel fleu et ça cire
l'école alors demain Philippe benassa
vous êtes maire de bois d'Arc qu'est-ce
que vous faites pour la croix Bonny vous
allez pas raser les non ce qui est
engagé est engagé mais ensuite on fera
une pause dans les constructions on
s'occupera des gens et du quartier on
s'occupera de d'animer ce quartier qui
est totalement mort on créera des aires
de jeu on nettoierera ce quartier qui
est assez sale et on le on essaiera de
jouer sur la sécurité aussi qui est un
problème à la à la croixbonnaete quant
au quartier du centrre-eville si je suis
élu je supprimerai cette ZAC
immédiatement pour créer en concertation
avec les riverins un nouveau quartier
beaucoup plus doux aménager vert et
absolument pas densifier comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui al je vous ai demandé
qui vous vous aimeriez avoir en face
comme candidat vous m'avez dit bah peu
importe peu importe en tout cas nous
nous sommes allés voir Claude Villet
l'actuelle maire socialiste de boisarcy
pour lui demander qui achève donc son
troisème mandat pour lui demander s'il
était prêt à se à se le relancer à se
représenter Sophi valal lui a posé la
question on écoute sa réponse j'ai
encore rien déclaré mais euh on en
reparlera si vous voulez bien pour
l'instant vous ne vous placez pas ah
benah je me place je suis à la mairie de
boisarcy je me sens bien j'ai une équipe
solide autour de moi bon ben on va on
envisage l'avenir bien évidemment mais
je vous dirai ça le moment venu si si je
me représente je me représente alors je
suis plus un gamin c'est vrai mais au
cas où je repartirai je porterai une
équipe avec une partie des élus qui sont
déjà avec moi qui travaillent bien et
puis peut-être des des personnes hommes
ou femmes nouveaux ou nouvell
et puis on irait vers l'avenir voilà
mais je vous dirais tout ça vous
envisagez quand même ah benah tout est
envisageable tout est envisageable oui
alors tout est envisageable mais il ne
dit rien il dit il ne dit rien on sait
pas c'est la diplomatie de de du maire
de boisarcy Claude Villier qui est
habituel je pense qu'il s'organise il
prépare son 4e mandat avec ce qui se dit
même dans son équipe c'est il va à cette
élection pour passer la main en cas de
victoire immédiatement ce que les
arcisiens apprécient encore moins parce
que quand on va au combat on assume
après ses responsabilités ça c'est c'est
ce que vous pensez vous oui c'est ce que
j'ai entendu c'est ce que je pense euh
donc c'est ce qui se dit aujourd'hui à
bodarcy c'est qu'il va faire sa campagne
il veut gagner et passer la main ensuite
en tout cas nous il nous a r rien dit
là-dessus euh mais justement vous votre
liste alors elle en est où la liste est
est-ce que bah elle est forcément pas
pas encore finalisée parce que c'est
bien trop tôt avant mars mais vousera la
rentrée oui oui oui oui on la travaille
on la travaille sur plusieurs axes
d'abord euh ça sera une liste du de
droite et du centre mais également c'est
une élection locale donc j'aimerais et
ça en prend le le pli en ce moment
rassembler toutes les compétences
arcisain et notamment la compétence
économique et la compétence entreprise
ce qui est absolument absent dans
l'équipe aujourd'hui socialiste il nous
faut aujourd'hui pour boisarcy pour
réaliser les actes dont je vous ai parlé
tout à l'heure le cadre de vie
l'environnement la non densification
urbaine l'attractivité économique il
faut de la compétence marchande dans une
équipe municipale aujourd'hui vous avez
vous avez tendance centre droit euh
centre droit pardon et centre ça veut
dire udi possible oui udi bien sûr j'ai
des j'ai des j'ai des colistier on va
dire ça comme ça maintenant colistier
udi sur la liste bien évidemment bien
sûr bien sûr donc une liste plutôt très
politique pas du
tout non non j'ai répondu sur le plan
politique c'est la liste d'opposition
actuelle mais il faudra qu'elle se
qu'elle s'ouvre aux compétences
arcisiennes au monde associatif qui est
très important à Bois d'Arcy qui est
très sensible à notre discours en plus
et ça sera une liste pour gagner une
élection vous savez comme on dit un
trottoir sil est bien entru entretenu il
est pas de droite ou de gauche il est
entretenu point donc c'est un peu le
c'est il y a quand même une couleur
politique oui bien sûr mais on peut pas
faire c'est une ossature dans une liste
mais on peut pas faire juste de la
politique pour faire la politique on est
là pour aussi représenter tous les
arcisiens d'accord merci en tout cas
Philippe d'être venu sur le plateau du
statut votre list elle sera elle sera
connue quand ou fin de l'année fin de
l'année d'accord merci beaucoup d'être
venu